I like this this is nice people should
see this
[Music]
jeez everyone is getting political these
days oh my gosh that ass foul language
ah
too stressful that's why I've never
voted you've never voted holy [ __ ] you
guys can talk yeah he's right you need
to vote everyone knows that how do I
know who to vote for what if I vote for
the wrong person
what depends what issues are most
important to you for instance I am sick
and tired of foreign cabana boys coming
in here and taking American cabana boy
jobs and I have a ton of debt racked up
from cabana boy college so I'm going for
a candidate that will help with that
cabana boy college loan companies need
to make a profit Luke okay I don't even
know what you guys are talking about how
did you learn this basically asking
questions and figuring out what's
important okay wait so you're telling me
if I want to get political I have to
leave this Beach and figure out what's
important to me
may I suggest your ability to purchase
an automatic rifle gun rights
what about poverty you socialist peg you
racist monster Phil oh I will wall wall
this is crazy I I don't even know what
side I'm on if I'm on anyone I told you
the wall I guess it's time to learn how
to be political I'm with her
I'm with her I'm
[Music]
as smart as those cabana boys were I
wanted to get an expert's perspective on
getting political so I went back to
college to speak to a professor of
political science next right science my
question is are all elections this
stressful level with me yeah do people
get a grasp on politics as Abe Lincoln
said by the people of the people for the
people how do the people even know what
is going on how do they know what are
the issues
it is media I think it's incumbent on
people to look at different sources
Donald Trump is the surprise candidate
and he's certainly not the darling of
the Republican establishment now how did
he get to be the candidate it was
through votes who figure that professor
actually know what she's talking about
if I really want to learn about politics
I have to talk to multiple sources okay
I can't just be brainwashed by social
media feeds so I hopped on a plane and
flew to the greatest show on earth
Republican National Convention in
Cleveland
[Music]
it's hot my Spanx are sticking to my ass
so this is actually my first year voting
why should I vote for Trump I really
love Trump stands for America first I
know that he's not really a Republican
so that really turns me on
I don't think Jenny Ron yes what do you
think I would have sex without cover
absolutely really why should we vote for
Trump we're young well I think we should
be the most concerned because we have a
lot of uncertainty about our future hey
gun what do you do have a lot at stake
okay we're gonna be the ones living with
these decisions a lot longer than anyone
else voting but still we bow less than
baby boomers for instance in 2012 only
46 percent of Millennials voted compared
to 69 percent of baby boomers if you
think we should be voting sixty-nine
percent and not our parents cuz you
didn't vote in 2012 either so yeah but
like now I'm learning and this is the
whole [ __ ] videos but shut the [ __ ]
up [ __ ] I'm gonna vote did I touch your
gun
uh yeah poke it there you go
[Music]
they sent me over Vietnam in 1969 I
thought that but now there are big
trading partner with us
they make apps and make tennis yeah you
remind me of my dad kind of oh thank you
shrunk has talked about a Muslim ban
that kind of seems totally against
freedom of religion which like isn't
that what our country's about heck
that's the first amendment heck one of
our fundamental rights freedom of
religion absolutely let's talk about the
wall uh yes way whose pain that is it
even gonna work does the president have
the authority to say we're building a
wall if you're looking at a constitution
that seems to be something he's got to
work out with Congress we don't have a
king you can't speak for me man no I
said my own opinion well right remember
we the people we vote a meal and we can
vote you out yeah yeah don't don't be
doing anything stupid cuz we we have the
power more important than anything you
have to know with what is important to
you for me
self-defense Second Amendment is very
important I'm a constitutionalist game
Epoque Constitution of where I go the
second page I mark is the tenth
amendment in that states the knee job
not grant to the federal government
article one section eight o'clock
the people I just read Twitter that's
really where I get all my news I follow
a lot of different political
correspondents do your research on the
down ballot that's gonna be more
important what the [ __ ] is a down ballot
so the down ballot is gonna be your
gubernatorial race is your Senate races
your local congressman stuff like
abortion I just kind of stay away from
you should be able to do whatever you
want I mean goodness the marriage god I
think I'm in love with you there's no
excuse for not doing your research we
have the internet now I try and look at
both parties and all candidates by pages
most you have their own websites and
just put them into google LGBTQ issues
are important to man and women's rights
issues are very important to me I'm
scared to get my rights taken away
I would like more reform on how you fund
colleges because we're both college
students I dropped out of college is
three of them yeah yeah well you know I
drank a lot here the whole thing
honestly I am against abortion but what
if they got in a situation that they
don't want kids I understand hmm I don't
joke you wear condoms so it seems like
Donald Trump doesn't really care about
women's rights and LGBT issues which is
a big thing that I care about but I
don't really know how Hillary would
address these issues as president either
but look I found out what I cared about
and that's my first tip I know what
issues are important to you as much fun
as the people in Cleveland where I
needed to hear from the other side of
the political spectrum too so I flew to
the Democratic National Convention it's
hot as [ __ ] here in Philadelphia
there are a ton of people out here you
start to form opinions I mean listen I'm
a very loud person but I feel like I
don't really have a lot of important
stuff to say I'm just intimidating you
know do you think all these people have
important things to say they sure sound
like it please they don't have an open
carry law here that's true you know I
think the greatest danger is if people
say I'm not gonna get involved what the
heck it doesn't matter
that's not how democracy is supposed to
work
this is actually gonna be my first year
voting what should I care about the
people and what's best for each other
most people are [ __ ] so you know as
Millennials what would you say to other
young people that are saying well I
don't really like either person so I'm
just not gonna vote vote for somebody as
long as you having a say in what happens
to you that's what matters yeah it's not
just red and blue it's green yellow
purple fuchsia we need to get rid of the
people that are currently running there
are four branches to the American
government so yes go ahead
judicial legislature uh executive and
what's the fourth branch independent we
the people Oh
people need to start paying attention
and I must get attention it's hard to
ignore the big fluffy thing walking down
the road I'm not saying that the
presidential race is not important but
what's happening on the local level is
important that determines where the
money goes for your schools your
libraries your roads and all the
infrastructure and as an academic
professor I challenge students and young
people to think critically don't just
accept the status quo and so your
opinion and your voice and your vote
does count and it does matter
I personally of course would not vote
for Trump Hillary is like your vegetable
like you don't really want it but like
it's good for you and then you have your
Donald Trump who's like the McDonald's
that no one actually
that they like what a surprise
and what a second to see you here today
Cleveland just blink away now where did
you say when we talked to you first that
you like it's from is definitely trumpet
fella flip-flop a nice course possible
business yeah that guy's right elections
are about business no give this [ __ ] as
of August 31st 2016 the Trump and
Clinton campaigns together have spent
over 1 billion dollars that's billion
with a beat I said [ __ ] that's a lot of
money people receiving that money
include campaign workers V networks
merchandise manufacturers people who
rent office space in stadium security
travel companies if you've got an
industry it's hard not to be impacted by
the money spent in an election as
someone who avoided politics like the
plague this conversation has definitely
sparked something inside of me to get
involved and want to learn more and
that's what politics is all about having
the conversation to make a better world
so I should take my voting
responsibilities seriously and you
should rejoice in having a real say in a
way that people in many countries do not
have do you want to rejoice with me
ah yes so after a week of getting
learned on by Democrats and Republicans
I needed a goddamn drink so I went to
one of our nation's oldest bars the City
Tavern in holy [ __ ] that's Benjamin
Franklin
I'm kelcie don't see it what brings you
here uh beer here sorry what are your
thoughts on the [ __ ] that's happening
today are you happy with that do you
think you made a good friend language on
this woman oh I know times are different
I didn't tell you that what they call
millennial yes well I remember being the
Federalist but a federally democracy a
stable government the freedom of
religion Oh decoration is also about
don't let me tell you Benny hmm some
[ __ ] has changed so there's these two
people one guys named Donald Trump never
heard of them and then there's Hillary
who might be a woman oh what the first
female president what do you think about
that very odd we're gonna play a little
bit of government trivia well you've
been very involved with American
politics this week tell me about it
we're gonna ask you a question if you
get the answer correct i Dre yeah if you
get it wrong you guys agree when was a
woman first allowed to vote in this
country [ __ ] I should know this was it
eighteen to nineteen nineteen now that's
[ __ ] up I'm gonna go with 1920 okay
drink as much as you can he's a good one
who is Gary Johnson he's a Republican no
he's an independent he's a green keep
going he's a liberal
no that's [ __ ] he's running for the
libertarian huh I sent you some liberal
no well it's a new liberal and
libertarian are very very different
okay yeah so turns out those three white
men are right people talk about a
political spectrum which usually goes
from conservative to liberal now
Republicans are conservatives and
Democrats are liberal but opposite sides
of the spectrum right turns out
libertarians are more conservative than
Ravel again unless we're talking about
weed then that goes somewhere over here
other good knows there are the Green
Party the Constitution Party the Peace
and Freedom Party and
bunch of other small ones not to mention
independence so find someone who likes
what you like even if that's on a local
level and vote for them yeah I got it
honestly be honest with you do you think
I was ever gonna of oh really I'm
realizing like how much I'm gonna be
affected after this election and how
much my opinions do matter to me yeah hi
it's time for me asking you guys a
little trivia question
oh all right god hope you got your
drinks ready mm-hmm am I on my period
right now if we knew that I know like
you're not cuz you haven't gone to the
bathroom enough if you were after
speaking to supporters and academics
across the country I flew back to
California where I'm finally ready to
actually vote but I don't know how do
you actually vote I mean can I do it
online here emesis what this looks
interesting
let's hello hello um is this a place
that I can vote Polly please oh yeah of
course
um I finally found out what issues
matter to me so now I'm here to learn
how to vote we'd love to help
yeah like love love it that's it's
really comforting now are you registered
to vote
oh I don't know how do I find out
um lunch go to vote usa.gov then I can
help you yeah he'll be good you can vote
in person or by mail in person on
Election Day go to your polling oh wait
back up I don't know where that is Boyle
how'd you find us online there you go
dude what'd you find that way to vote go
there and cast yeah well but what if I
can't leave work or I'm out of town or
I'm lazy well then you get to cast a
mailing bow
first you request mailing bail you fill
it out then you mail it in
thank you puppets I'm so thankful for
your help though there you have it a
[ __ ] got political turns out
being political isn't that hard
you just have to figure out what matters
to you should be pretty easy figure out
what candidate also cares about those
issues that's a little bit harder
register to vote just to calm I for
Christ's sake go there do the goddamn
thing I know you've heard it before but
it's true you need to go out there info
and once you do boom effecting change in
your community and ultimately
very philosophical it's very much
outside of ourselves we are part of
something bigger neil degrasse tyson
guys 2020 does he say that reporting him
directly no I just think it'd be dope if
he was president he's a real nice guy
anyhow hey guys that was the first
episode of my new show am I doing this
right it was [ __ ] good right it's
basically like a crash course on how to
be a grown-up even if you don't feel
like what the rest of the series drops
in December only unwatchable plus all
this elections crap will be over by then
we can celebrate that by watching am I
doing this right
[Music]
watchable